hallo herzlich willkommen zum neuesten
ausgabe der heute show und wir stellen
fest die welt wie wir sie kennen steht
vor dem untergang meldung von heute die
lindenstraße hört auf gut dass vater
beimer das nicht mehr erleben muss man
ja es ist herbst es ist die zeit der
abschiede auch angela merkel wissen sie
hat ja schon ihr bündel geschnürt und ja
es ist
es ist ein phänomen wirklich sehen das
mal aufgefallen seiten kanzlerin gesagt
hat dass sie als parteichefin aufhört
hagelt ist in den medien nur noch
lobeshymnen
wenn merkel das geahnt hätte hätte sie
wahrscheinlich schon viel früher den
sack gehauen und müssen wir sagen ihre
erfolge sind ja auch gar nicht alle zu
bestreiten
stichwort frauen niemand lacht ein
junges mädchen heute mehr aus wenn es
sagt dass es später immer ministerin
oder sogar bundeskanzlerin werden will
ende letzten jahres es soll sogar schon
es soll sogar schon fragen geben ob es
auch ein mann werden darf jetzt ist ja
absurd heißt jetzt an zu spinnen einmal
als kanzler wie soll das denn gehen aber
schon verblüffend wirklich verblüffend
wie merkel plötzlich als ja quasi schon
historische figur von allen gefeiert
wird von allen gut jetzt
nicht in ostdeutschland aber in
deutschland halt bei manchen
kommentatoren steht sie ganz kurz vor
der seligsprechung dafür muss man bei
den katholiken mindestens ein wunder
vollbracht haben mir fallen spontan
sogar 3 1
merkel hat es irgendwie geschafft dass
nach all den jahren aufschwung immer
noch zwei millionen kinder bei uns in
armut leben
ein wurden dort drei jahre diesen
skandal drei jahre ohne dass ein
einziger autokonzern zur verantwortung
gezogen wurde wahnsinn
und ihre regierung vergeigt trotz teurer
energiewende wirklich jedes klimaziele
53 wunder freunde drei wunder man steht
hier noch bei den katholiken
man muss ein martyrium erlitten haben so
hat sie auch oder ich finde schon
doch natürlich
gott hat die frau unter oper gelitten
wahnsinn zumal das müssen wir an rechnen
sie frau merkel geht wenigstens in würde
halbwegs das schafft er ja leider nicht
oder ist echt tragisch ich finds
tragisch horst seehofer gibt zwar den
csu parteivorsitz im januar auf aber
innenminister will er unbedingt bleiben
ich bin bundesinnenminister ich sag's
ihnen wie ich gerade gesagt habe ich bin
jetzt in einem ministerium bleibe
innenminister es ist so und es klappte
luca war klage noch mein gott die
sogenannte alters putzigkeit das glaube
ich ja um den ihr los zu werden braucht
man wahrscheinlich ein exorzismus
ich fürchte mit diesem personal wird die
krise der volksparteien ungebremst
weitergehen aber selbst daraus kann man
ja ein event machen
live aus der dortmunder westfalenhalle
das abschiedsfest der volksparteien mit
florian silbereisen nostalgie pur
die cd all stars mit es ist vorbei
bye bye volkspartei das legendäre hit
wonder martin schulz mit im wagen vor
mir wild einer die gründe und natürlich
djs heuer mit seinem party hit party
sage ich doch jetzt tickets sichern
es gibt nur noch ganz wenig restkarten
wie viele 200.000 einengt geiler spaß
mit wirklich allen hits
ja ist gut jetzt folgt das abschiedsfest
der volksparteien hoffentlich ist es
bald vorbei
[Musik]
das abschiedsfest der volkspartei
vielleicht ist die zeit der
volksparteien vorbei gut müssen wir
sagen bei der cdu bringt immerhin der
kampf um den parteivorsitz frischen wind
rein
es treten an wissen sie ak jens sparen
und friedrich merz für mich der mercedes
benz unter den kandidaten meine güte ist
halt reich der frites hot spot selbst
beim bild -zeitung stalkt wird
heutzutage nur noch sozialneid geführt
sind sie millionen
warum sagen sie nicht einfach ja
eigentlich als ein blick auf die zahlen
das ist gar nicht so viel wie man glaubt
was zahlen sie für eine gute flasche
wein
was jetzt noch weiter senkt das fängt
mit vier euro 50 an
besitzer der oberschicht also ich würde
mich zu der gehobenen mittelschicht in
deutschland zählen faustregel wer mehr
als ein flugzeug besitzt ist
wahrscheinlich nicht mittelschicht so
merke ich es mir immer fürs protokoll
der kann so reich sein wie er will geht
uns nichts an
problematischer ist in welchen
aufsichtsräten der mann sitzt und dass
man alle seine künftigen entscheidungen
als kanzler danach beurteilen wird
derweil versucht die andere ex
volkspartei namens spd
herauszufinden wer sie eigentlich ist
und das ist eine gute frage muss ich
sagen
gute frage deswegen haben die sozen zur
selbstfindung gerade ein so genanntes
debatten camp in berlin veranstaltet
motto gute laune jetzt erst recht
lasst uns über uns so reden die wir sind
ihr sind nämlich spitze mit viel spaß
dabei und das hatte ich in diesem
bericht spaß spaß spaß das war ihr
letztes wort
dann trugen sie die pfleger fort und
warum auch nicht warum dann nicht
klarkommt
[Applaus]
spaß haben
denken
es gab so viel schlechte nachrichten für
die sozen warum nicht mal spaß haben im
prinzip hat die spd bei ihrem
sogenannten debatten camp einen
riesengroßen wunschzettel geschrieben es
ist wahnsinn was da alles auf steht
höherer mindestlohn hartz4 komplett weg
was man halt so sagt wenn die basis
einen endlich wieder lieb haben soll
und das hängt nicht hatten die sozen so
viel spaß am letzten wochenende dass sie
jetzt hinter dem willy brandt haus in
berlin im hinterhof ein dauerhaftes camp
einrichten und genau da schalten wir
jetzt mal hin zur genossinnen birte
schneider
frau schneider was ist denn helfen sie
mir die idee hinter all dem camp neue
wir als spd wollen halt mal klären wofür
wir stehen im jahr 2018
wofür gibt es uns noch das sollen uns
jetzt die bürger mal sagen weil wir
haben echt keine ahnung hat jemand
vorschläge anregungen
das ist nicht der fall herr welke warum
denn nicht nur mit gleichgesinnten kreis
sitzen und träumen debatten camp ist wie
so ein fantasy rollenspiel einfach mal
so tun als wäre die spd eine linke
partei vorschläge sammeln von denen man
weiß dass man sie umsetzen muss deswegen
habt ihr auch zwölf euro mindestlohn
gefordert
ganz genau die groko in der wir ja
irgendwie auch dabei sind hat zwar
gerade erst neun euro 19 beschlossen
aber kommt egal merkt keine sau oder
hier vorschlag von spd generalsekretär
für jedes jahr arbeit fordern wir einen
monat bezahlte auszeit
umgekehrt find ich geiler ach so wie
herr 100 arbeiten zwölf monate frei oder
ja gut dann machen wir das ist notiert
wenn du das geiler findest schreiben wir
das hier auf dem wunschzettel klar doch
kein thema da reden wir drüber
deswegen heißt es ja auch
die banken kämen wir hätten es auch man
müsste echt mal kämpfen können oder
hätte hätte fahrradkette kämen ja wann
lernt ihr das endlich wenn man den
bürger immer wieder hoffnung macht und
dann nicht liefert gehen die leute von
der fahne eben nicht wir gewinnen sogar
neue leute dazu hier ist szene vom
letzten wochenende
ich habe den eindruck dass ich weiß du
zu uns ja ich bin seit april der spd
mitglied ich bin noch sehr frisch aber
ich bin
danke aber es könnte auch sein dass ich
wieder austrete
ja und
aber für kabel hatte war sie
spd-mitglied so auch mal das positive
sehen
also wir machen weiter vorschläge hartz4
wird abgeschafft
geil oder ja und dann wird es durch
irgendwas anderes ersetzt was genau das
klärt ein zukünftiger zukunftskongress
in der zukunft sonst noch wünsche
irgendjemand ich möchte ein pony pony
kriegst du kriegst du pony vielleicht
2021 ich möchte dass meine frau zu mir
zurückkommt du klar
meinhardt also was soll denn der scheiß
ich konnte nicht immer weiter sachen
fordern und dann in der groko das
gegenteil machen ja gut in der groko
jetzt vielleicht nicht nicht mit der
union aber ich sag mal so das setzen wir
alles punkt für punkt um wenn wir
irgendwann endlich allein regieren
nicht lustig würfel schneiden
[Applaus]
[Musik]